الينا هنا في الاستوديو مامون حميدان مدير
عام شركه ويجو في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا اهلا بك صباح الخير صباح النور
اهلا وسهلا خلينا نروح سريعا ما هي
النصائح اللي تعطيني اياها حتى اسافر
بتكلفه اقل واستمتع برحلتي هلا بالتاكيد
دائما بنركز عليها انه الحجز المبكر احنا
مع الاسف مشهورين في المنطقه
شهور تقريبا يبتدي يبتدي البحث والتخطيط
والترتيب وخصوصا موضوع الفنادق بالمناسبه
الطيران مرات مرات الاقرب للرحله بالوضع
الطبيعي ننسى الظروف مع بعض الكورونا
المختلفت قد تحصل العرض او تحصل سعر جيد
لو كان فعلا لكن الفندق مستحيل فندق خطه
قبل واحجاز ابل وحافظ على
كان اقل احسن طيب استخدام مواقع
قناه الاسعار بشكل عام بتفيد بشكل كبير
اكيد بتعطيك عده خيارات من البحث ممكن من
خلال توفر خصوصا لو مسافر للسفر بيكون
عائله توفيق لو كان بسيط الجمع بكون بكون
مفيد
اختيار وجهات اللي خلينا نقول
او او فرق العملات بساعد فيه وهذا اليوم
يعني مثلا في العالم العربي مثلا عربي
تقريبا العملات خلينا نقول خلينا بشكل عام
متقاربه لكن لو لو شفنا مثلا تكلفه السفر
على سبيل المثال لو اخذنا مثلا شرق اسيا
بكثير من الدول فيها اختلفت امور
الاكشنريت او او
العمله مصر كوجهه محببه من المنطقه من هون
تكلفه التركيه
حتى حتى يعني او الوجهات المرتفعه
التكاليف خلينا نقوم البريطانيا اليوم
بحثنا سعر الباوند اليوم 29 سنه عندما كان
عليه قبل قبل ثلاثه او اربع سنوات بشكل
كبير وبالتالي تكلفه الانفاق اللي حتكون
هنيك قال
شغله اخرى منضل مثلا بقرا بانه اذا بتحجز
باليوم الفلاني او اليوم الفلاني خصوصا في
يعني
تذاكر الطيران بتحصل ارخص من سافرت اليوم
ارخص بكرا لو سافرت الصبح ارخص ما اسافر
بالليل اعطينا تفاصيل
بشكل عام هو الابتعاد بشكل منطقي يعني
بيكون كل الناس
من اول لحظه رحلات صباح الباكر دائما
بتكون اغلى لانه الناس زي وجهه نظر السفره
كانت طويله فانا حاوصل باول يوم بالتالي
بكسب يوم كامل للراحه
الليل افضل
مفيده جدا يعني احنا هون بنحب السفر
الدايرك دائما
عنا ما شاء الله شركات طيران كبيره فدائما
تعودنا
الافضل لو انه ممكن الواحد يعمل توقف ولو
كم ساعه او يوم يكتشف في مكان جديد
وبالتالي بخفض كثير من كلفه التذكره
الكثير حتى في العالم العربي اليوم قاعد
يتخوف من الطير يعني قليل التكلفه ما
دائما يروح على الشركات اللي هي معروفه
لكن هذه الشركات اليوم اصبحت حتى اسعار
الخدمات اللي تاخذها ضريبيه عليك اكثر
بكثير من ما قبل كورونا هل هذا موضوع عرضه
طلب
خلافه كثير اساطير من الطيارات والوقفت
وبالتالي الكبسه خلينا نقول العرض الموجود
اليوم في السوق قلب كتير من الطلب موجود
حتى اللحظه توقع لنهايه هذا العام ان شاء
الله بترجع كل المقاعد اللي كانت بتوفرها
قبل للخدمه بالاضافه للشركات الجديده
للطائرات
فالمفروض تاثر على على الموضوع الطيران
وخفض التكاليف ثقافيا نحن لسه عنا
متعودين عليه بينما هو في اسيا بجاوب ارج
اسيا في اوروبا في امريكا داخليا يعني
موضوع كبير جدا هو هو بصراحه المحرك
الاساسي
بعجاله هل السفر الفردي يختلف عن السفر
اجتماعي هل مثلا اذا سافرت مع ناس بتكون
الكل في علي اقل طبعا وخصوصا اليوم مع
خيارات السكن البديل اليوم هي الترند
الحاصل حاليا اكيد بيكون في فرصه لمشاركه
التكلفه شكرا جزيلا لك مامون حميدان
مديرعم شركه ويكو في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا شكرا شكرا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات